you know if we start following these
retail brands on Facebook Twitter I
think the one place to really start
paying attention to is Pinterest and
Instagram are emerging as well but
across these platforms these are
becoming the new email services email
open rates are declining these social
networks are growing and so I would
focus on following the retailer's of
choice across these platforms though not
all the retailers are doing a good job
is this now that the biggest social
media meets commercial shopping day that
America has yes but also don't forget
about cyber monday so a lot of these
people that if they're these companies
are playing on these platforms they're
also very much focused on cyber monday
so a lot of these you know bricks and
mortar stores they're trying to grow
their business in Walmart and Target and
Costco they're paying attention to the
Amazon's of the world so they're trying
to grow their cyber business cyber
monday is becoming a very real player in
this whole equation of a weekend as well
how do you think companies in America
generated bigger ones are dealing with
this new emerging superpower of social
media you know it's funny I've been
paying attention a lot of this new book
I wrote is focused clearly on all this
so I've been paying attention a lot you
look at somebody like Macy's of looking
at them yesterday I'm so impressed with
how they're so focused on Pinterest and
Instagram and then you look at Best Buy
or Sears which you know it hurts my
feelings I'm sure some of their
executives and employees are watching
but it's an utter disaster
they just are not focusing on it I mean
Sears our Best Buy I can't remember
which one now posted their TV commercial
as a Facebook post nobody's on Facebook
to watch your 30-second TV commercial